hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play dead space sorry for the
voice crack anyway um what's your face
Kendra stole the marker back I guess
that guy supposed hi quit hanging out
there helpless guy um where am I going
back out there
oh I guess this does leave right to the
shuttle's so this would be a good way to
cut her off all right here we go hello
baby
I'll come I'm home oh this is goodies
fire sticks yay whoa hey hold it
together
hi this yes get her get her shoot her
cheddar cheddar oh oh you should have
run faster lady oh oh crap
Evan legit all that awesome on
oh you want some I'll come to give me a
big ol hug
hey my goodies hahaha hey big guy oh
it's you pretty little thing hot damn I
get to kill that this this makes sense
whatever I love me some yellow at least
I'm not walking card at least I'm not
being held while Chikatilo things a
sweeter is our holy crap oh that did
that hurt you shouldn't trust your weak
points right at my face oh wow what the
hell oh okay I got a Dodge
Oh balls come on I'll be like that holy
crap sobbing oh [ __ ]
ah now I hadn't have a say
these I'm not being oh good lord no
please
got one got one okay hey stop no please
we'll still double your picture mom for
the camera
Oh Oh
I gotcha I gotcha
okay thank you
not so good as it turns out there's some
goodies uh-huh where can I go can I do
what maybe I can use Mike whoa what the
hell is that oh you got to be kidding me
put that off boom thingy oh they can
kill you get dead
get up Isaac got work to do
not God not gun baby comes with the left
and then right
open up open up open up their yard
Oh miss miss come on come on there we go
come on all fair out all bad is this
cosplay
come on open up open up buddy open up
right right right right
daaad epic epic slow welcome
come on open up open up there you miss
good damn it there we go got one
oh god I should just switch to the other
op dodge dodge dodge dodge dodge yeah
why don't you be
of God
and if you're this fat I hate to see
your mama get one there we go okay
switching to the other one god I can't
shoot worth a damn come on open up
now slowly warm
swerving
listing lazily
bro
Oh
pay the new business
that meteor doing
got away meteors got to be getting
pretty close
the jungle
come on one more one more I got it I got
it I got it
Ernest maybe you should open that up to
me
Yaya
and are you actually better you just
bye-bye bye-bye
okay time to get back up on the ship hey
come on
okay am I going back up okay yes what
about the marker do I do something with
the marker
something can I take this with me or
something seems it bored okay whatever I
just go up
run run run man get it run oh that did
it apparently
sweet
I'm escaping up there's the big meteor
took over whatever you want to call all
that don't whoa
yeah I imagine I remember they were
saying little guy was millions of tons
so if that crashed back into a planet
from orbit that'd be pretty bad what I
want to know is how they lifted it in
the first place that seems pretty
improved
oh I think this is it oh there's his
beautiful face ah look at him he's so
handsome he looks a bit old to have
Nicole for a girlfriend and he's got
some gray in his hair I see
good job buddy you so awesome cuz you
got me
I wish I could talk to you and so I did
that start auto-playing
that's no good alright okay
I knew something was up okay
holy crap that was it oh my god that was
that was a really really awesome game I
mean that was probably the most fun I've
had for $5.00 in a long time and it was
$5 because on a special steam sales now
$5 but I got this and esri Super Bowl $5
so wow that was pretty incredible I
really really enjoyed the game and I
really enjoyed the fact that I never got
stuck
not once because it was always that
handy Waypoint system that pointed me in
the right direction every single time
whoo oh man this is this is probably the
longest let's play of a single game that
I've done it is like gonna be a 36 part
thirties it party too hot damn that's
a good number of parts and I know I've
only been literally playing it for about
a week and a half still comparatively
down longer betraying the channel that's
a long time big percentage just
dedicated one game so thank you all for
watching I really appreciate it I can't
say enough how much I am grateful for
you guys I say that a lot of credits but
just looking back at where I've gone and
I was I was like I thought I was
grateful back when I had 500 subscribers
and I was saying how amazing it was that
you guys supported me but right now I'm
looking at about climbing up to 1750 or
more I don't know I recorded it before
it came up so it may be a different
number now
getting close to the 2000 mark and
that's another big milestone for me and
I couldn't have done it without any of
you guys I just can't say anything other
than thank you so much for doing this
helping me get there I know if you
haven't checked it out a lot of doodles
to come up if you haven't checked out
the live stream channel I do live
streams so far I've just been doing
Diablo 3 but I'm going to expand it into
Daisy other games some more games SCP
containment breach add basically
whatever comes to mind that I think
would work well but I'm kind of in a
diablo 3 skin because I love that game
it just came out but if you haven't
checked it out please do i've also in
case you haven't know there is the
minecraft channel i'm still working on
that i'm trying to split my time evenly
between the three ventures because i
basically three channels that i'm trying
to work on the live stream my main
channel and the minecraft and trying to
juggle them all is a bit of a struggle
but I'm doing it for you guys because I
know you guys
want to see everything the fact that we
change to the 15 minute Rio de schedule
on the main channel really is helping me
out because that means I have to update
less I can record more at one time and
it have it still be in the same episode
and basically it's just more enjoyable
this way for you guys so but that's all
it is for just summing up what's
happening so thank you guys again so
much I literally can't thank you enough
I know that's a cliche that said of
equally but it's true you guys are the
heart and soul of this channel
without I would be nothing and I'm
without you god I would be nothing I
would be struggling to get even a
hundred subscribers by now if if it
weren't for you guys so the fact that
I'm even approaching 2000 is astonishing
so thank you guys so much that's all I
can say thank you guys so much and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye